Herkese
merhabalar herkese öncelikle bu güzel
davetiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
sizlerle bir arada olmak çok keyifli Ben
Duygu Yılmaz böyle bir şirketin kurucu
ortağıyım öğretim görevlisi gıda
mühendisiyim
Aslında bugün de konuştuğumuz gibi
kendimizi bulmak hayattan hayatta
bizimle mutlu ediyor Çünkü o kadar çok
Aslında mutlu olduğunuz alanda başarıyı
açık bir sistem var ki sadece biz bunu
hayatın içerisindeyken fark edemiyoruz
Ben ben inanılmaz çok ders çalışmayı
seven bir çocuktum Benim annem önünden
kitapları topluyordu arkadaşlarımla aynı
şekilde hala de hep söyler ilkokul
arkadaşlarım üniversite lise
arkadaşlarım genelde hep böyle bir saat
oturdum konuşurdum sonra tamam hadi ben
derse gidiyorum ders çalışacağım Niyeyse
beni hep bu
kısım kitaplarımda çok seviyordum
kendine baş başa kalma yeni bir şeyler
öğrenmeye çok severek yetiştim
üniversiteye çalışarak okudum İlk olarak
İstanbul Aydın Üniversitesi'nde tam
burslu gıda mühendisliğini bitirdim okul
biter bitmez tekrar üniversite sınavına
girdim İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi
Kimya ya bu sefer de kayıt oldum eğitimi
aşkım hiçbir şekilde bitmediği için
Sonrasında da mastıra başladım içinde de
o dönemde Aslında her ne kadar
lisanstayken çalışarak okusam da ilk
Mühendislik yaptım firma bir kurumsali
bal firmasına hemen işte kabul aldım
mezun olur olmaz itiyor başladığım
dönemde derken bir buçuk yıl kadar orada
çalıştım ve o süreç içerisinde aslında
Çok da nedense ilk kurumsal profesyonel
deneyimimizi çok mutlu olmadığını fark
ettim kendimle ilgili bir arayış
içerisine girip dem24 yaşındaydım ve o
dönem ve bir hafta sonu kahvaltı da
babama baba okulda görüyorum bir boyutta
girişimcilikle ilgili yazılar var Ben de
okulda bazen geçince ki etkinliklerine
katılıyorum hafta sonları ve ben de
kendi işimi kurabilir miyim acaba dedim
Benim ailem Genelde herkes memur
herhangi bir işletme Kuran yada işleten
hiç kimse yok Ticaret L çok ağır arası
Yok hiç kimsenin babam içinde ardından
korkutucudur
çok da yapacağımı düşünmeyerek ben
Kahvaltıda zeytin çekirdeği uyutuyorum
sen Gıda mühendisinin zeytin
çekirdeğinin içerisinde acaba ne var bir
araştır dedim sonrasında Ben zeytin
çekirdeğini araştırmaya başladım ve
içerisindeki antioksidanlar üzerinde
çalışmaya başladım zeytin çekirdeğinin
hikayesi Beni o kadar çok etkiledi ki bu
sefer kurumsal hayatın ayrılıp zeytin
çekirdeğinin içerisindeki
antioksidanlarla ilgili bir iş fikri
oluşturmayı düşün bu düşünüyordum Yani
biyoplastik üretmekte ile bir gıda
takviye ürünüm derken zaten üniversitede
plastiğin zararlarının üzerine
biyopolimerler ile ilgili çok fazla
araştırmalar yapmıştım ama seni 2014 ve
gerçekten hiçbir şekilde yani ne ülkemiz
ne dünya Bio plastik ile ilgili
yeterince bilgi sahibi değildi Ben
Zeytin çekirdeğinden bir plastik
üreteceğim diye işten ayrıldım şu anki
ortaklarım olan içinden hazırlıktan
arkadaşlarım Fatih ve Emine Aslında
öğrenci kantini de kafa kafaya verip
Zeytin çekirdeğinden nasıl plastik
üretebiliriz diye bir yola çıktık tabi
ailem arkadaşlarım süreç içerisinde çok
beni algılayamadı lar part-time bir iş
buldum bir etüt merkezinde üniversite
sınavına öğrenci hazırlamaya başladım
hafta sonları full Gece yarılarına kadar
Hafta içi de akşam başlık yine geceye
kadar genelde hep etüt yapıyordum
öğrenciler bu ve gündüz evde zeytin
çekirdeğinin plastik üretmek için
öğrenci evinde kurduğumuz laboratuvarda
çalışıyordum Fatih'in evinde bir
laboratuvar kurmuştuk and imkânlarımız
da yaklaşık iki buçuk yok Zeytin
çekirdeğinden plastik üretmek için
sayısız denemeler yaptık ve sayısız
makaleler taradık üçümüz
2016'da ilk prototip ipimiz bitti Fakat
o süreç içerisinde öyle bir noktadayım
ki işi bıraktım ailem ve arkadaşlarım
tarafından algılamıyorum gerçekten ailem
Akli dengemi yitirdiğimi düşündü yani
Zeytin çekirdeğinden Plastik nasıl
üreteceksin diye gittiğim her kapı
yüzüne kapanıyor genelde yani Hem
akademik tarafta hem iş dünyasında
anlatmam çok zor oluyor zeytin
çekirdeğinin üretilen plastiklerin çok
daha sağlıklı olacağını sonra 2016'da
bir ışık doğdu ve Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
bir yarışmasında ikincilik elde ettik
Biz Almanya'ya gönderdiler eğitime giriş
bu ilgili ve orada gittiğimiz
numunelerle elimizdeki küçük O
plastiklerde çok fazla ilgi çektik
oradaki üniversitede ve sonra doğru
yolda olduğumu düşündüm çünkü Evet belki
Türkiye o dönemde hazır değildi ama
Global bunu hazırlanmış özellikle da
Avrupa plastiğin zararları üzerine zaten
birçok Aslında regülasyonlar
zorunluluklar getirmeye başlamıştı ve
bazı firmalarda vergilendirme ile Ceza
yaptırımı uygulanıyordu firmalara
kullandıkları plastik miktarına göre
sonrasında biz Türkiye'de döndükten
sonra Türkiye'nin önde gelen
kurumlarından birinden yatırım aldık ve
kendi laboratuvarımız açtık üniversitede
derken
2017'de 28 aydan sonra artık Zeytin
çekirdeğinden ürettiğimiz plastiklerle
küçük küçük ihracatlar yapmaya
başlamıştık elektronik dan tekstile
gıdadan çocuk ürünlerine Medikal
sektörüne kadar birçok Aslında
hayatımızda olan
plastiklerin her o uyumlu bir malzeme
geliştirmeye başardık dünyada ilk olan
bir teknolojide sonrasında silikon
Vadisi'ne Gittik iki kez ilk olarak
Amerika'da Los angeles'ta Ülkemizi
temsil etti ve ileri malzeme birincilik
ödülü aldık 2017'de derken hızlanmaya
başladı 30 aşkım ulusal ve uluslararası
alanda birincilik elde etti özellikle
bilimsel çalışmalarla ilgili
sonra işler büyümeye başladı ekip
gelişmeye başladı yeni ekip arkadaşları
aramıza girmeye başladı fakat çok küçük
yani metrekare bir alan da biz üretip
satıyorduk bu plastikleri daha fazla
talep gelmeye başlayınca elimizdeki
bütçeyle daha fazla diyemeyeceğimiz fark
ettik ve sonrasında tekrar bir yatırım
arayışı oldum önce de 3 ortak gittik
Amerika'ya sonra ortakların döndü ve ben
Amerika'da Yaklaşık dört Arkadaşlar yeni
tekrardan ikinci yatırımcı aramaya
başladım işleri daha büyütebilir ve
sonrasında Türkiye'de Benimde çok
sevdiğim bir grupla anlaştık ve yatırım
aldık şu anda daha büyük bir işletme
kuruyoruz o yatırımla Fakat bunlar ha ne
kadar için büyüme noktasında kalsada
Beni en çok mutlu eden kısım Bugün bizim
ürettiğimiz benim yıllar önce o kahvaltı
masasında heyecanlanarak ve sonra
aylarca
Araştırdım o Zeytin çekirdeğinden
polimer nasıl üretimi Fikri şu an birçok
Global markanın Otomotiv iç aksamında
nişte diş fırçasına kadar ürünlerine
ürünlerinde artık kullanılıyor ve her
gördüğümde rafta gördüğümde herhangi bir
yerden Reklamını gördüm de inanılmaz
duygulanıyorum ve benzin mücadeleye
hatırlıyorum Çünkü bazen o 24 yaşındaki
o kızın ışığı isteği azmini özlüyorum
Çünkü biz zaman sonra o kadar çok
yükümlülüklerimiz artık ki artık o
araştırmacı ruhumu azaltmaya başladı mı
fark ediyorum ve bu beni bazen
endişelendiriyor de bundan iki yıl önce
de bu sefer deri benim gerçekten yani
deri sektörü beni neden rahatsız etmeye
başladı ayakkabımız da çantamızda
kıyafetlerimizde ya hayvansal de
kullanıyoruz ya da sentetik polipler
plastikten üretilen de kullanıyoruz ve
Aslında bakıldığında her ne kadar
hepimiz plastik çok büyük zarar gibi
görsekte malzemelerin birçoğunun hep
üretim proseslerinde hemde müşteri
geldikten sonra hem de o döndü sele
konuya katılmama kısmında ciddi
zararları var sonrasında bir Tekstil
partnerinizle beraber ben ve eden bir
çanta almıştım O günde toplantıda onu
takmıştım bizden üretemez miyiz diye bir
işbirliği ile gittim ve iki firma bir
araya gelip şu anda dünyanın en yüksek
bitkisel oranını derisini üretmeye
başardık O da çok ilgi görmeye başladı
fakat bu
2015'te Paris Barış Konferansı'nda
açıklanan Bu bir Kalkınma amaçlarının
biliyoruz ki 2030 yılına kadar birçok
firma Karbon ayak izini azaltmak zorunda
yani sadece firmalar değil Bizler de
kendi verdiğimiz doğaya verdiğimiz o
zararlı ne kadar hızlı bir şekilde
Götürebiliriz düzenli artık kafa yormaya
başlamalıyız ve bu süreçte bu hedefler
doğrultusunda bütün üretim prosesi ve
belki de Türkiye'nin ilk yeşil tesisi
olmayı planlayarak yola çıktık Umarım bu
konuda önce oluruz Çünkü ben Dünyaya
geliş amacımızın Sadece bu dünyadan
geçmek olduğuna inanmıyorum Eğer Bizler
bir şeylere karşı önlem almazsak yarın
belki ileride benim torunlarıma rahat
yaşayabileceği bir tabiat kalmayacak
burada o yüzden bunun mücadelesini
şimdiden vermeliyiz Bence öncelikle
doğru bilinçle doğru kullanımdan sonra
da aldığımız her önündeki asla malzemeye
dikkat ederek bile bunu da diyebiliriz
ben gerçekten dünyaya kendi geliş
amacımı küçük de olsa biz katmak
olduğuna inanıyorum
çocukluğumdan beri bütün Aslında
hedeflerim ancak hayal olarak zihnimde
canlandırıyorum hayal ediyorum sonra o
hayallerime Hedef olarak görüyorum ve
başardıktan sonra yeni bir hayalle
yoluma devam ediyorum Umarım Sizlerde
her zaman hayallerinizi ve tutkularının
peşinden gider ve çok mutlu olursunuz
Çok teşekkür ederim